hello everybody here today
aye aye when they decreased stopped use
I don't speak English fluently but I I
bring is amazing top key for talk to use
and I I has been my my wife - she's my
my boy same in the walk-in home she's my
manager of my life and we stay here for
for top to use about this incredible
awesome to Tahoe topic about this matter
yeah excessively in yes yes start now
first of all I just said thank you for
crews three civilians and ojs confer
organization and Cesar and all my
sponsors and so thank you all for coming
it's our pleasure to be here that's K
let's get it starting now
oh yeah yeah JSC along the time was
being pointed to as villain who who who
is who here never listen any disc jockey
about job scripting along the years I
walking with JavaScript
I listen many liars about JavaScript and
today I say here for talk to us and try
to cleaning these bad reputation because
job streets are a good guy not bad guy
because and stay here with all my family
and this is amazing placing because
JavaScript in any other things but I it
I keep going because now meeting short
three thirty minutes and annoying
this is no 18 today for day today hey
why why I say here for talk about the
accessibility why I should I invest on
it or why
around the world account to un have
60,000 660 million and 50 million people
have some some kind of special needs and
in his more fortune in my country is a
45 one more five four five million it's
a it's a represent to me it means almost
winner of twenty percent of the
population it for me it's it's sound
greats of opportunity at business in
another think e of the Box the wound can
can be screwed for the great men's minds
sorry people
it's like English is not my mother
language the phrases
yeah but these eyes is they see for
hawks is a strongly guys from bear
person I love you should already and did
they know that's okay I think they they
was loose if anybody to means a simple
task well if nobody matter demolish
things that we have would have loosed
progeny term a bit avec Foom you can
also think about Beethoven most of the
songs that he has written his katana
like Sabra daily and
[ __ ] beta the postal code sued the
post once he couldn't hear anything then
that's when he wrote his most beautiful
songs I love another another another
means as a imagine supersaurus precocity
- guten musica doom so who do ya and can
we imagine if people didn't care about
songs written by people that could not
hear at all but did that did not happen
so Beethoven turned out to be one of the
most famous composers of all times we
need to think out the box and sometimes
we I I try to talk about accessibility
for and other guys another developed guy
in anybody no matter because it can be a
tough until a miski or anybody don't
know about accessibility is effective
it's so [ __ ] a sub super accessibility
helmet merciful I don't really know what
accessibility is all about what the
accessibility is a it's nothing to do
because it's not accessible many guys
try to make the application accessible
but it has nothing to do with this image
at all it's a and I just to say for
youth anything isn't often a accessible
that cannot be improving not a now that
ptosis is okay no Passos ml or at the
time that's what's written over there
sorry these are finger new accessibility
because we have time thinking about the
days that is that key person in our
symbol
Iza
it's a new project for two - to try to
change because it's a we we need to to
see it another way because those peoples
are able and active and that pain and
anger gee many disability people are
engaging in the ice open scientific hugs
for example yeah just think about seven
hawks and that's it
and many other people but who needs
accessibility we always we thought about
accessibility and blind people both but
it's not naughty not one not just one
but it's all timing with we thought
about and which is necessary to need
think about temporary disability a motto
of Australia motto when you get injured
and then maybe any of you guys here
could be in that situation and perhaps
needs some kind of accessible feature oh
that is about the interaction design
because almost importance of technology
is not technology in pro permitted it to
keep going but it's a people innovations
are made for people those universities
so innovation is made from people to
people one is a colorant blind people
these are meaning levels the great
colors in the people said some somebody
an adult audience yes can see they write
colors in the
people for different ages and countries
and kids for instance so for example our
case when did it they didn't know how to
write they just touch the speech button
on the search place in the application
and they'd would screen out the name of
the show yeah yeah let it go frozen it
perfectly worked like oh thank god I
don't need to write that now we don't
leave don't listen
Weedon so yeah don't forget about people
who can't listen you can hear because I
always remember that they might need
subtitles or even the transcriptions
that they practice here reduces
philosopher all a solid tutelage in the
parking I have just say that maybe
people can feel SSL thinks about
documentation is a most important
because we too need to know about the
documentation but it's it's an episode
similar to happen even though it's
extremely rich very some people may get
scared because the amazing alphabet soup
I mean but today we focusing focusing in
the quality accessibility because we
need public aid not in our application
our applications in this wai-aria why
aya is the most important for for for we
because of the channel tataki along
along there's a presentation i just to
to to help the forefront asking for they
this CC edgy is a
dd-do path this path is divided for
basic principles
yes the passive able perceivable
understandable preparado and most robust
perceivable is the distinguishable
information we need to provide
alternative texts in the application is
a adaptable time Bethenny Maria is a
adaptable with - actually isn't many
talk about responsive web design and
another another things an operable a
novel application to needs navigates
navigate for for keyboard because some
people don't don't can can use in our
application with the the Mullens in to
need the pepper sauce queues or take on
this positive la cabeza forces there are
people who can even wear gadgets and
into your heads and use them to access
your applications but normally those
people's use it that if they depend or
enter that seems strange but some
people's do you'd like to use the
keyboard to navigate on their websites
most important see of that sliding is
the dead pointed desert portal my third
point because a what do I not saying
cool is so much peaceful these may cause
seizures so you need to be careful about
the colors you use if it's blinking too
much yeah it's automated
oh gosh my swatch body as I said was a
picker so much some people develop at
some applications
something really interactive with light
blinking all the time to emphasize
something recommendation that says that
you cannot blink more than three times
per second okay Salta because I can
cause you and also the colors
combination because if there is a red
line blinking too much people can also
it can call also play me so much closed
scissors a little bit dizzy you may get
a little bit dizzy
keep going understand both the ladies is
a very understandable because but a
double CG is in our application could be
less evil thanks a private evil you
think they'll protect predictable has
it's in photosystem so we are going to
explain a little bit more in in their
future it's a key possible I can tell
that it's kind of the god of software
development because this is what
everybody wants is that your application
works in every single device in every
resolutions and all browsers platforms
everywhere and that requires a lot of
effort right we can do it yes we can
user agents do
because user agents this guy can be are
now a user agent normally blind people
use this guy but this guy can be
inaccessible because this guy is very
expensive this maniac space because this
guy is very training very next it
requires a lot of training in Brazil for
instance it can cost you like sixty
thousand Brazilian reals what would be
like twenty thousand US dollars win yeah
but so that's not accessible at all
but normally we know customers we are
used to that we needed browse data has
up a problem with along the soft
development
my name is embarrasses the end of
different browsers is for we're on day
one also our big as was something that
we're really scared about some time ago
I told me to hell daddy Tom poke mellow
at the realities changing my isn't
normal little bit better but we still
had faced a lot of problems when
developing myth browsers understand
engineer the browser is very good but
it's not it's not only fish my tell me t
lk theorem italic disowned and also time
that explains sometimes we cannot sleep
at night just think about the solution
to resolve this problem but normally we
usually swim hit screen readers it's a
text-to-speech the application yeah I
I've been to you the out Petrie yeah you
can send it for this because probably
with no hole that's left top so you can
see how old is he honest technology our
application interest for me invoice and
a researchers about the the most of must
use any screen readers thank you baby
thank you sweetie
in other ways yo Socky I brought this
here this is rice more specifically
because some people asked Philippi wine
are you worrying about accessibility in
mobile applications why would a blind
person use it in their mobile device and
I'd like to answer to those people the
same way that we use it they can also
use it it's a change in the mindset
right human right basic human right yeah
and this is night I brought to you to
show you what we need to do to make it
compatible with we have to do more than
because we we have to to teacher in our
browser in our user agents opposed to
the Fidel filari
until they can actually speak we need to
teach the user agents how to speak okay
this is not actually very difficult so
if you can observe this code I've
written it's a very extremely basic HTML
but this is the kickoff point the
starting point it is right
some people make some basic mistakes
right when they're writing their codes
they don't care or they forget to set up
the correct doctype or even the language
it can you screw everything up if you
can if you do not set up it in the way
that a screen reader can can use it the
screen reader will try to read your text
in a language which is different from
the one you had set so it's going to
screw everything up so oh no browser
choose to say all they read the page
another means how at barriers and every
JavaScript unless abilities
I need Minnesota University I I read in
the paper of them say I Samara Sumer up
that ain't for principle bias it's a my
vision about all day the saying the
asteroid I read about the about that and
they're the first one is a the browsers
don't support JavaScript oh hell
disability disability disabled disabled
JavaScript it's a big line but it's uh
today it's a big lie a long time ago
it's a mini it's all Amir Hadad Sarah
half-truth yeah you can see what I said
but ninety seven percent support
JavaScript I have enable and my grandma
used JavaScript and she don't know about
its mean yeah it sounds not fair with
JavaScript
she blames have escaped 2004 another two
percent we we need to to
give them some alternative so that they
it's any anybody whose name is no
Microsoft it kind of sport not even
Microsoft wants to give support to it
but yeah yeah my my PES of the nightmare
a long time ago I don't need to worry
about it anymore
another another code is a Microsoft dev
is a we have to need to think out the
boxing in our approach because I did
piss apiece I need to think how can I
say that animating about the did fight
browsers so you'd write a different code
depending on the browser that you would
be using but instead of that Microsoft
has designed a code that would detect
the features compatibility in set of
browsers another by here is a lack
knowledge of the area prions are fo that
Mozilla devs I this is a cache follow
and this is what they talk about in
music between accessibility Andrea's yes
connects ssible nsj if I did not exist
could not work with accessibility at all
that's the workflow how how it's working
usually agents interact interactive if
they ask this technology able for a
stone dissolve Aria it's a one my heroes
John assigned a credo of the magic Barry
yoga nidra girl trouble I had already
won a lot of money using jQuery thanks
to him
Jake JavaScript code item a magic relief
at simple topic is Tommy actually exists
another amazing frameworks like they the
Angela and Oliver forever
today right today in our life is a very
easy easy
but the the guys form is a P&L of the
frameworks in language you've just
forgot to mention and what he said on
the previous line that it's already
implemented so it's not a dream rules of
Aria Aria thank you Aria in sable this
to say no way in browsing jeans or
another user images agents as this
technology for the piece of the decode
it's a html5 is a most similar key but
these are able really cement key to for
almost all the the engines okay rich
Internet application with subjects
of all time but we 5 minutes
it's amazing we know about you Jax I
think so or somebody uses don't know
about that yeah they made my hero to a
real life is a only way for for
interactive application which the
applications to to quicken saga billets
are do nothing that can really enable ok
oh great problem at this has acute
process cannot understand when some
contents are updated on the webpage all
most important it's our only way for for
in its we animated rich Internet
applications here's another another
rules in another you know that time you
stay here all along the rivet I can talk
to you about that it's a sample as a as
a poor example it's a very very very
easy but it's unnecessary a difficult or
impossible navigation with keyboard is a
big problem we have because any
application don't know
don't able navigate to keyboard is are
not aiming about the links we can can
edit 8 the avoid avoid is in Chinese
name is generic names yeah because the
names I think as foolish thing to say
compressing because I mean a screen
reader is going to read it the user will
not understand it appropriately so you'd
better choose a long description
to help them out peony about this tip
navigation is a meaning important for
application because we title that cannot
can never reach the contents so you can
raise this skip navigation method so use
this with CSS to outline to kind of
highlight the place where the people is
navigating through the keyboard so this
approach to obvious keeping the
navigation is extremely efficient but
you need to focus to the you need to set
the focus correctly and the JavaScript
as well
because if you cannot set the focus when
you're going to navigate the focus go
back to or
change to a different place so it can
mess everything around this is another
example that is very cool for you to
understand when you're learning
accessibility I think you break this off
German and Acosta you need to I didn't
think I saw Moodle it's terrible a cool
mobile to think about mobile and then
they say that they did does not work
because some applications some mobile
applications do not Macedo clicking the
click events that you can use the touch
screen or even the keyboard this is
another approach to show the same menu
to open the same anyway in here isn't
the keyboard and finally what would be
the great speakers of the accessible
applications
so here I brought to you the champions
there were some contests in Versailles
so those were worthy winners and you can
see that they have that kind of menu at
the top the right top left top from
where you can control the contrast the
the font size or skipped it and I skip
to the content so those are really basic
things that your website or your
application should consider and so here
I brought you an example of how to
control the font size increase or
decrease it how to set the contrast
right so I wrote a sample of this code
and it's already available on github for
you to contribute if you want
it's called side by side Jes and the
creator of the web says that we can know
we always need to care about the
standards need to be comparable with
with them and the message I really
brought to you today is that the most
important thing after all is that we
need to know about where area
interaction design interactive design
and I'm sorry but I could not I did not
have the time to talk about what can you
repeat that
okay so we hope you guys enjoyed it and
if you want to know more about that
matter that that topic you can just look
for us after this I assure all of it
Saturday me yeah if you come up da da la
da so yeah he goes you know told you'll
say lucky toffee you yeah make yourself
at home
thank you thank you